(audience cheering)
Thank you for doing this.
You stress the importance of financial independence
for women.
And why is that personal for you?
So I didn't come from money.
As you know, I grew up in an immigrant family.
I started as a poetry major Drew.
So if I could do this,
literally anyone can do this.
And so I realized that it's actually not that complicated
and it became my mission to take the jargon out of this
because I think that's what makes it so scary
and so taboo.
You do have to realize that money is a language
just like anything else.
If you go to Japan and you don't speak Japanese
you'd be really confused
but then if you speak the language
you can understand it and join the conversation.
The same thing with money.
If you go to Wall Street
and you don't speak the language of money,
you'll be really confused.
But here's the thing,
you can't budget your way into wealth,
you can't even save your way into wealth.
Those are great things.
Your base salary is not even gonna grow you
long term wealth.
The only thing that will is investing
and utilizing that amazing force of compound interest
that has so often been used against us
in the financial system with credit cards and mortgages
where it snowballs out of control.
Well, you can take that control back
and use it in your favor.
Well, what is the first step?
Start now.
You don't need a lot of money to make a lot of money.
If you tell yourself that
those are just stories you're telling yourself.
You need the most time possible.
Einstein calls this the eighth wonder of the world
where compound interest your money
literally makes money for you not doing anything.
You don't need to look at stock charts all day.
You just have to set it and forget it.
And honestly, today is as good a day as any,
you're never as young as you are today.
Actually that's an important point is age,
age matters.
It absolutely matters.
I'm glad I didn't invest earlier, said no one ever.
All right, well, we actually had some audience questions.
Our first question comes from Diamond by the way,
best name ever.
Hi drew and Nicole.
I'm a mom of two little ones ages three and 10 months.
How do I get them to become financially literate grownups?
Okay, that's a little young.
However, when you hear a question like that,
what goes through your mind?
And what's your advice?
The reality is our kids are not learning this stuff
in school.
If I were in charge of the world, it would be different.
So it's incumbent on us as parents to help our kids
become financially literate.
And you can implement little concepts.
Like if your kids wanna borrow money
from you for a big purchase, you can charge them interest
if they pay late.
You can have an allowance go on a sliding scale
or have them negotiate for an allowance
or even ask them how much a car costs.
This is a fascinating conversation with a kid, by the way.
To give them a concept of how much things cost.
But here's the reality Diamond, wherever you are,
it doesn't matter if you are not financially in control.
Your kiddos are watching you.
A lot of our financial habits and morays
happen from our parents.
Whether they spent frivolously, they were outta control,
they hoarded, they coupon clip,
they got into debt,
so your kids are watching you.
You have to put your oxygen mask on first,
even before a helping your kiddos
because they're copying every financial move you make.
Our next question comes from Brittany in our audience,
Brittany.
So my question is,
as someone who's in the last year of their twenties
what should I be doing to be financially successful
in my thirties?
You have the luxury of time.
You don't need a lot of money to start
if you have that much time.
So for easy map, let's say you put a hundred bucks
into an index fund that tracks the market.
If you started at 25, by the time you're 65
you'd have a million bucks.
Oh wow.
If you start at 35
and that's only $12,000 of a difference, right?
A hundred bucks a month, times, 12 months, a year, times 10,
you would have $300,000
when you're 65.
Wow.
That's a $700,000 difference
just based on compound interest.
So start today.
I definitely will, thank you.
Okay, I've never heard anything like that.
So you take a hundred dollars a month.
If you have the privilege of that kind of money
and you invested in an S&P 500
for most of your life,
by the end, there will be something there for you.
Yes.
And with each year
and each decade that will decrease.
Over time,
we wanna beat inflation, right?
We've been hearing all these headlines about inflation
which is about 3%.
So you at least need to inflation proof your money.
What are you getting in a bank account right now?
Or a checking account?
That's where a lot of women put their money,
less than a percent.
If inflation's at 3%,
you're losing 2% of your purchasing power.
So inflation is just stuff costing more tomorrow
than it did yesterday.
So when little Drew was going to a movie,
how much did it cost?
$2 and 50 cents.
How much does it cost today?
It's about $17 a person at this point.
And then that doesn't even count for the candy counter.
Right, and if you transport little Drew
with her $2 and 50 cents, she's not getting into a movie.
And that's why you have to make your money work for you.
You work so hard for your money.
It's time it returned the favor.
So over time, the market or the S&P 500
which tracks the market,
gets you about 7% inflation adjusted.
Your book is just so incredible
because numbers can be overwhelming,
finances can be so stressful,
but you talk about the human experience
as well as give such sound financial advice.
So you're who I wanna be following.
And nothing makes me happier than seeing people succeed.
So guess what?
Everyone in the audience is going home
with a copy of Nicole's books.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, Nicole,
'Miss Independent:
A Simple 12-Step Plan to Start Investing
and Grow Your Own Wealth'
is available right now.
Now, we all have it and you can too.
Go buy it, we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)